[Music]
I think we have all the tools we need
now to stave off real terrible climate
suffering and I think the problem is
essentially a political a problem of
political economy it used to be the case
that there was a kind of strong economic
conventional wisdom that said that
action on climate would be quite
expensive both in the sense of upfront
investment and in a sense of forgoing
economic growth because you'd have to
say stop burning coal before the coal
plant was actually ready for retirement
but the new there's a huge amount of new
research in this area that reverses that
logic completely which says that faster
action on climate would actually be
would offer huge economic payoffs in a
quite short-term way there was one big
study in 2018 that said we could add
twenty six trillion dollars to the
global economy just by 2030 through
rapid decarbonisation I think that
estimate maybe a little rosy but it
suggests just how completely this
conventional wisdom has flipped just in
the last few years I don't think that
understanding has yet risen up to the
level of our policymakers who are still
a little bit bound by the earlier
perspective that we'd have to forego
economic growth to take action but I
think it will get to them soon and I
think our policy and our politics will
change actually quite dramatically when
that happens so I don't think it's a
question of money I really think it's a
question of political will through the
green energy we have now through the
knowledge we have about infrastructure
and agriculture it is within our power
to take action and avert our worst-case
outcomes it will always be the case that
what damage is being done to the planet
we are doing ourselves that is a sign of
just how much power we have over the
climate and we could channel that power
towards action against global warming
rather than in the direction of more
carbon emissions we'd be in a much
better place at the moment there's great
excitement and movement on climate I'm
heartened by that I think there's reason
for optimism but it's not happening fast
enough we really need to take action
very very quickly the Secretary of
General of the UN says that we need a
global mobilization against climate at
the scale of world war two beginning
this year 2019 and so when the numbers
of people who believe in climate change
and are worried about it
they've jumped 15 points in a few years
that's incredible it's almost unheard of
in political science I put by the
measure of political science that change
is happening very fast but we need much
faster change even than that we need to
start right now and our politics is not
yet responsive at that level
[Music]